you took your kids on a trip recently to
Mississippi well yep
of course that's for most people
vacation you got family there obviously
yeah very obviously yeah we have family
there and it was fourth of July and a
lot of bonfires on the beach is nice
got to hang out with I think it was
eight cousins and water parks and just a
lot of a lot of fun yeah and then we
stayed actually at a Holiday Inn and my
wife when we were going to check in when
we pulled up she said are we in a suite
and I was like I don't think there are
Suites at Holiday Inn we we normally
stay with our family but this particular
trip was crammed with so many people so
we ended up staying at the Holiday Inn
and just really had a great great time
we thought and then when we got home we
asked the boys what their favorite part
of the vacation was and Max said he
really loved sleeping in the bed did you
guys all share is that happened well in
our suite we we had two beds right and
Stefanie slept with one child I slept
with the other and max just he loved it
he I just felt like you know we could
have stayed home I can truly relate to
this because like a few summers ago I
took my wife and I took our kids on this
really nice trip to France and we're
showing them the French countryside and
doing all these cool stuff and then we
go to Paris and we see all that then we
come home and there was a problem with
our flight so there wasn't a connecting
flight in New York so we stayed at this
really small kind of like motel right
near JFK Airport yeah and we just stayed
there we all crammed into one room and
slept on one bed and we got home and I
asked my son what was the best thing
about the trip and he's like oh man that
Airport you're JFK that was fence high
he loved that the best he thought that
was fantastic how old was he he's 44
years old
[Applause]